hey it's evan and if your business is
not where you want it to be then you
need to do better i was looking at my
youtube channel today and it's been
great to see all the increasing views
over the past couple months I've passed
half million views and each video seems
to get better and better I don't think
it may not these readers should be
better these videos I want to get more
people on the channel I want to impact
more people want to reach more
entrepreneurs and I realize that you
know what this is on me the videos have
to get better the production has to be
better the quality the answer has to be
better everything about my youtube
channel has to be better if I want more
people to watch it if I want to have a
greater impact and if I want you guys to
share it more if your business isn't
where you want it to be this is on you
something is wrong you have to make the
experience better so stop blaming other
people stop blaming the environment the
economy whoever else get in there make
it better add more value fix it and
you'll start getting the results that
you want good luck hey you like this
video please give it a thumbs up below i
love seeing knows and if you have a
comment about this or question for your
business leaving a comment section below
i always read those love seeing them
come in thank you guys i'll see you soon